you
you
you
you
how do check 1 2 1 2 1 2 audio check 1 2
3 4 5 6 8 9 10 audio check 1 2 3
Radio check 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
audio check audio check 1 2 3 4 5 6 now
you want to okay let me go talk to them
you
one two three testing testing can you
hear me
is that okay one two three testing
testing this is the English booth hello
one two three testing testing this is
the interpreter English one two three
testing testing
No
channel one of your receiver is english
channel two is Spanish Channel one
English Channel - Spanish
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States and the president of
the United Mexican states thank you very
much it's a nice hot day it's quick but
it's all very positive that I can say
and it's my tremendous pleasure to
welcome everyone to the White House my
good friend president Lopez Obrador
of Mexico we've had a very outstanding
relationship mr. president were truly
moved that you chose to make your first
foreign visit since taking office very
successfully taking office I might add
to be with us at the White House the
relationship between the United States
and Mexico has never been closer than it
is right now and as the president said a
little while ago people were betting
against that they were actually betting
against that it's but it's never been
stronger never been closer we're doing
tremendous job together
we're cherished friends partners and
neighbors our cooperation is founded on
mutual trust and mutual respect between
the two of us and between our two
countries and we honor the great dignity
of both nations with his visit president
Lopez Obrador
and I have the opportunity to strengthen
the bond we afford since his impressive
election victory more than two years ago
a victory the vice president and Ivanka
joined in celebrating at the swearing-in
I was a very exciting day for them each
of us was elected on the pledge to fight
corruption return power to the people
and put the interests of our countries
first and I do that and you do that mr.
president the tradition of great respect
between Mexican and American presidents
goes back to the early days of both of
our nation's
and in particular it includes President
Abraham Lincoln and President Benito
whereas we tell one another and very
very high esteem there were great
friends and they did great things
together and we are grateful that this
morning President Lopez Obrador laid a
wreath at the memorials that stand to
each of these leaders right here in our
nation's capitol that was very beautiful
beautiful ceremony
our countries are linked by trade and
travel by history and culture by faith
and family the United States is home to
36 million
incredible Mexican American citizens
Mexican Americans uplift our communities
and they strengthen our churches and
enrich every feature of national life
there are hard-working incredible people
they are also great businessmen and
women and make up a big percentage of
our small business owners and very
successful they're very very successful
they're like you they're tough
negotiators and great businesspeople mr.
president working alongside president
lopez obrador
we're taking this relationship to new
heights and building a powerful economic
and security partnership together we
have addressed many of the most complex
issues facing our two countries that
really went unresolved for many years
and frankly far too long should have
been resolved long before I got here but
we're achieving great strides and
remarkable breakthroughs and
strengthening our relationship for
decades to come
with everything that we have
accomplished the potential for the
future of the United States and Mexico
is unlimited far far greater situation
really for both countries than anyone
thought possible today we celebrate the
historic victory we achieved together
just days ago when NAFTA was officially
terminated
one of the worst trade deals in history
and replaced with a brand-new beautiful
US MCA we want to thank Canada also I
spoke with and will be speaking to the
prime minister in a little while well
NAFTA
last wages and eliminated jobs the u.s.
MCA includes groundbreaking labor
protections for workers in both nations
this landmark agreement will bring
countless jobs from overseas back to
North America and our countries will be
very big beneficiaries we are already
seeing the fruits because it's started
it's the largest fairest and most
advanced trade deal ever reached by any
country and it will bring enormous
prosperity to both American and Mexican
workers and Canada we want to thank
everybody will have a separate day with
Canada they're coming down at the
appropriate time but we want to
congratulate Canada and the people of
Canada the Prime Minister but this has
been a tremendous achievement sexualy
the largest trade deal ever made and we
made a big one with China too but this
is the largest trade deal ever made our
two governments are also in close
cooperation to stop the illicit
cross-border flow of drugs and guns cash
and contraband and very importantly
stopping human trafficking
we're forging critical partnerships
across the Western Hemisphere to combat
the cartels and the smugglers and to
ensure safe humane and lawful migration
and we've been helped greatly by Mexico
on creating record numbers and a
positive sense on our southern border
it's been really very very tight and
done a great job and I want to thank
secretary who's here we have a Chad
you're here someplace where is Chad what
a good job you're doing Chad great job
we're proud of you and you've worked
very closely with Mexico I know you were
just telling me what a great help
they've been thank you very much we've
also worked closely in the battle
against the corona virus together saving
countless thousands of lives it's been
my honor to help Mexico procure 600
ventilators and it's going to be a
higher number than that they needed them
very badly and we were able to make them
we're making thousands a week and we're
helping a lot of countries but one of
the first and maybe the first that I
spoke to was Mexico
a lot of them in Mexico saving a lot of
lives and mr. president we're in this
fight together and we're doing very well
it's just a couple of things on that
proud to further announce that the u.s.
is by far number one in testing number
one in the world and testing and that
the mortality rate is the lowest or just
about the lowest of any nation anywhere
in the world and we're safely reopening
our country and very importantly we're
safely reopening our schools we want the
schools to be open and going in the fall
and most of them I think are looking at
it that way it's very important we're
finding out that learning by computer is
not as good as learning in the classroom
or learning on the campus and I think
you're finding that too we want to learn
in the classroom so our schools we want
them open in the fall following
president Lopez Obrador remarks will
sign a joint declaration committing
ourselves to a shared future of
prosperity security and harmony this is
truly a proud moment in history for both
of our nation's Mexico and the United
States with the signing we pledge the
close and continued friendship between
the United States and Mexico and we
accelerate our progress toward an even
greater tomorrow that's what's happening
a greater maybe even if far greater
tomorrow with a prospering region a
flourishing hemisphere and two sovereign
nations thriving growing and excelling
side-by-side working together and that's
what we've been doing mr. president we
look forward to hosting you for a
beautiful dinner later on this evening
with some of your friends from Mexico
and some of our great friends from the
US and it's an honor to have you with us
and please we'd love to have you say few
words thank you thank you very much
with you having been able to close the
[Music]
most of the world
agreement
reberty x2 refers imbalance integrate
economies in mejoras in the
bringing to our countries provided
content
disagreement when they deciding we work
together towards the we want to ensure
understanding
that's why differences are solving
in our society so United
we would be fortunate
thank you for your
is that you
[Music]
Viva Mexico
great job thank you and we will now sign
a very important document thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
nobody's really cool